vamos a hablar más sobre la tercera ley
de newton ya que hay muchas ideas
erróneas que muchas personas tienen al
respecto esta ley parece sencilla pero
no es tan sencilla como piensan muchas
personas se refieren a ella como que
para toda acción va a haber una reacción
de igual magnitud pero en sentido
contrario y esto es bastante vago como
para que no sea útil una versión que es
un poco mejor nos dice que para cada
fuerza va a haber una fuerza igual y
opuesta eso es un poco mejor el signo de
igual aquí significa que estas fuerzas
tienen la misma magnitud y ese signo
menos indica que son diferentes
solamente por la dirección que tienen
estos son vectores por lo que aquí nos
dicen que este vector verde efe tiene la
dirección opuesta que el vector f
magenta pero ambos vectores son iguales
en magnitud
pero para mostrarles cómo es que esto
sigue siendo un poco vago consideren
esto si sólo supiéramos esto de la
tercera ley de newton que para cada
fuerza hay una fuerza igual y opuesta si
ustedes son inteligentes se pueden
preguntar bueno a ver para cada fuerza
por ejemplo esta fuerza verde
efe
debe existir una fuerza igual solo que
en sentido opuesto y esto querría decir
que todas las fuerzas en el universo se
cancelan entonces no es que todas las
fuerzas en el universo deberían
cancelarse con esta tercera ley no
significaría esto que cualquiera
aceleración sería imposible porque si yo
aplico una fuerza f en algo entonces voy
a tener una fuerza f negativa que va en
sentido opuesto acaso esto no significa
que cualquier fuerza que yo ejerza va a
ser cancelada por una fuerza de la misma
magnitud y opuesta la respuesta es no y
la razón por la que no es así es que
estas fuerzas son ejercidas en
diferentes objetos y la razón por la que
esto no es cierto es que estas dos
fuerzas se aplican en objetos diferentes
por lo que debemos tener cuidado la
razón por la que les comenté que este
enunciado de la tercera ley de newton
sigue siendo algo vago
que esto ocurre en diferentes objetos
este va a ser para el objeto a ejercida
por el objeto be y esta fuerza de aquí
debe ser la fuerza que está en el objeto
be pero que es ejercida por el objeto a
en otras palabras estas fuerzas de aquí
son ejercidas en diferentes objetos voy
a mover esto a este otro lado pongo esto
por acá y vamos a dibujar dos objetos
diferentes para explicar sin lugar a
dudas a qué me refiero aquí tenemos un
objeto
digamos que este es mi objeto y tiene
una fuerza y está ejerciendo una fuerza
efe de color verde ese es mi objeto a
ahora vamos a tener otro objeto que es
nuestro objeto b
que se ve así y ese es nuestro objeto
ver y tiene esta fuerza magenta efe
de hecho es - efe que está ejercida en
este objeto y ahora vemos que estas
fuerzas no pueden cancelarse ya que
estas fuerzas se ejercen en diferentes
objetos y cuando nosotros mencionamos la
tercera ley de newton como que para
cualquier fuerza hay otra fuerza igual
pero opuesta no está claro de que se
ejercen en objetos diferentes pero si
tiene que ocurrir en objetos diferentes
estos padres de fuerza de la tercera ley
de newton pares de fuerza o fuerzas
compañeras de la tercera ley de newton y
siempre van a estar en objetos
diferentes en mi notación estoy con la
convención de que la primera letra
denota el objeto sobre el que está
actuando esta fuerza con la letra grande
es la fuerza que se encuentra en este
objeto se encuentra en este objeto pero
es ejercida por este otro objeto la
segunda letra que tengo aquí y aquí se
muestra que esta fuerza es ejercida
sobre b por el objeto
esta fuerza magenta se ejerce en vez
esta fuerza verde se ejerce no son
iguales pero opuestas y no se cancelan
no pueden cancelarse porque no se
encuentran en el mismo objeto
y tienen la misma magnitud incluso
aunque los objetos no tienen el mismo
tamaño esta es otra idea errónea
supongamos que el objeto b es un planeta
y nuestro objeto es una estrella digamos
que este es una estrella grande y este
es un planeta pequeño que está en órbita
de esta estrella y bueno este dibujo no
está escala sino este planeta estaría
enorme pero este planeta puede ser
cientos o miles o incluso millones de
veces menos masivo que la estrella pero
aún así sigue ejerciendo la misma fuerza
si esta estrella está jalando este
planeta con esta fuerza de color magenta
que llamamos - efe entonces este planeta
también está jalando a la estrella con
la misma magnitud pero en sentido
opuesto la jala con esta fuerza de color
verde y tienen que ser de la misma
magnitud
aun cuando los objetos sean de diferente
tamaño así que muchas personas citan la
tercera ley de newton pero en realidad
no están convencidos de ella si yo les
dijera que este planeta es un millón de
veces menos masivo que esa estrella las
personas pensarían que ya que la
estrella es más masiva pues va a tener
una mayor fuerza de atracción hacia el
planeta sin duda más grande de la fuerza
que ejerce el planeta jalando la
estrella pero de acuerdo con la tercera
ley de newton esto no es cierto ambas
fuerzas tienen la misma magnitud aún
cuando sean de diferente tamaño si este
objeto afuera la tierra y el 'we fuera
la luna la tierra jala a la luna lo
mismo que la luna jala a la tierra y aún
así ustedes podrían seguirlo dudando
cómo es posible que un objeto tan grande
como la tierra sea jalado por la luna
con la misma fuerza
digamos que nuestra estrella se mantiene
aquí y nuestro planeta va a estar dando
vueltas alrededor de ella como es que
este planeta puede estar dando las
vueltas y les
ya quedarse quieta pues justamente
porque las fuerzas tienen la misma
magnitud y el hecho de que las fuerzas
sean iguales no quiere decir que el
resultado sea igual las fuerzas son
iguales pero las aceleraciones no tienen
por qué ser iguales la aceleración va a
ser igual a la fuerza neta
dividida entre la masa así que incluso
aunque la fuerza sea la misma al
dividirla entre la masa entonces
obtenemos la aceleración y esta
aceleración va a ser diferente para cada
objeto y es por eso que mencionamos que
el resultado de la fuerza no tiene por
qué ser el mismo aunque las fuerzas sean
iguales las fuerzas tienen que ser
iguales por la tercera ley de newton
otra idea errónea que muchas personas
tienen es que piensan que puede haber un
rezago en la creación de esta otra
fuerza en la fuerza compañera de esta
tercera ley quizás así yo ejerzo esta
primera fuerza lo suficientemente rápido
podría quizás tomar desprevenido el
universo y hacer que esta otra fuerza
aparezca después pero esto no es cierto
la tercera ley de newton es una ley
universal no importa cuál sea la
situación sin importar cuál sea la
aceleración o falta de aceleración o
movimiento o falta de movimiento si un
objeto es más grande o más pequeño que
el otro
las fuerzas compañeras de la tercera ley
de newton siempre son iguales son
opuestas y siempre son iguales y
opuestas en cualquier instante de tiempo
incluso si yo tuviera a chuck norris que
está dando una patada a una pared voy a
tratar de dibujarlo aquí en el momento
en el que está por dar la patada aún
cuando yo llegara a volando para patear
esta pared justo en el momento en el que
estoy en contacto con la pared voy a
ejercer una fuerza en la pared y la
pared va a ejercer una fuerza en mi yo
voy a ejercer una fuerza en la pared
hacia la derecha y esta va a ser la
fuerza en la pared ocasionada por mi pie
y tiene que haber una fuerza igual y
opuesta que se va a transmitir hacia
atrás en mi pie esta es la fuerza en mi
pie provocada por la pared y eso sucede
instantáneamente no hay ningún desfase
de tiempo en esto no podemos patear esta
pared lo suficientemente rápido como
para que no se genere la fuerza de
regreso en el instante en que nuestro
pie toca la pared
cualquier fuerza que se ejerza en la
pared en ese instante la pared va a
ejercer esa fuerza opuesta pero igual en
el pie la tercera ley de newton es
universal pero las personas siguen
teniendo problemas en identificar estas
fuerzas compañeras o pares de esta
tercera ley una forma de hacerlo es
mencionar a ambos objetos si usamos esta
anotación y enunciamos los objetos
sabremos que solamente tendremos que
intercambiar estas etiquetas para
identificar qué objeto es en donde está
la fuerza y cuál es el objeto que la
ejerce si una de las fuerzas es la que
está en la pared debido a mi pie para
encontrar la fuerza compañera de esta
fuerza intercambio las etiquetas y puedo
decir que la fuerza en mi pie causada
por la pared es la que dibuje aquí y esa
es una buena manera de ayudarnos a
identificar las fuerzas compañeras de la
tercera ley de newton ya que no siempre
es sencillo identificar cuál es la
fuerza acompañante
mostrarles lo confuso que puede ser esto
vamos a ver un ejemplo digamos que tengo
el suelo y encima del suelo tengo una
mesa y por alguna razón en este ejemplo
enloquece a las personas si yo tengo una
caja que está encima de la mesa vamos a
llamar a esta caja y esta caja va a
tener fuerzas ejercidas en ella una de
ellas va a ser la fuerza de gravedad que
la va a jalar directamente hacia abajo
si yo les preguntara cuál es la fuerza
acompañante de la tercera ley de newton
para esta fuerza de gravedad les puedo
apostar que muchas personas me van a
decir bueno tengo una fuerza que va
hacia arriba en la caja que es ejercida
por la mesa y es cierto si esta caja
está asentada aquí y no se está
acelerando estas dos fuerzas van a ser
iguales y opuestas y es muy tentador
decir ya que estas fuerzas son iguales y
opuestas que son la pareja de la tercera
ley de newton pero eso no es cierto
estas dos fuerzas son opuestas iguales
pero es debido a la segunda
ley de newton esta segunda ley nos dice
que si no hay aceleración entonces la
fuerza neta va a ser igual a la masa si
la aceleración es igual a cero entonces
estas fuerzas netas se van a cancelar y
es lo que está sucediendo aquí esas
fuerzas opuestas e iguales se están
cancelando en la caja y esa es la forma
de darnos cuenta que no son parte de la
tercera ley de newton ya que las fuerzas
compañeras o la pareja de fuerzas en la
tercera ley de newton siempre van a
ejercerse en objetos diferentes y nunca
pueden cancelarse si pertenecen a la
tercera ley de newton lo que sucede aquí
es que tenemos dos fuerzas que se están
cancelando que son iguales y opuestas
pero no son pareja de fuerzas de la
tercera ley ya que están en el mismo
objeto y de ninguna de estas he dibujado
su fuerza compañera vamos a hacerlo
tienen que estar en algún lugar vamos a
quitar esto regresamos con esto y vamos
a irnos un poco más despacio
para encontrar las dos fuerzas
compañeras vamos a mencionar los objetos
que están interactuando esta fuerza
morada no la voy a llamar fg de hecho
tengo que ponerle que es la fuerza que
está actuando en el objeto a y esta
fuerza es provocada por el objeto que es
el planeta llamado tierra este objeto
que es el planeta tierra está ejerciendo
esta fuerza de gravedad en el objeto a y
esta fuerza de gravedad si queremos ser
cuidadoso es la fuerza que se ejerce
sobre el objeto a provocada por el otro
objeto que es nuestro planeta tierra y
ahora si me es fácil encontrar cuál es
la fuerza acompañante la podemos
encontrar simplemente intercambiando
estas etiquetas
así que en lugar de tener la fuerza
causada por la tierra debo de tener una
fuerza igual y opuesta que es la fuerza
en la tierra ejercida por la caja y si
es opuesta quiere decir que va a estar
apuntando hacia arriba y esa es una
fuerza que se ejerce en el planeta
tierra y es provocada por la caja
y es algo realmente bastante extraño de
imaginar porque aunque la tierra esté
ejerciendo una fuerza en este objeto o
en ustedes significa que también tanto
la caja como ustedes están jalando a la
tierra y podría parecer ridículo ya que
si por ejemplo nosotros brindamos pues
brincamos y volvemos a caer al suelo
nosotros nos movemos pero la tierra se
queda sin moverse y si las fuerzas
fueran iguales como es posible que si yo
brinco la tierra no se mueva nuevamente
esto es porque aunque las fuerzas sean
iguales la aceleración o el resultado de
estas fuerzas no tiene por qué ser igual
la aceleración no es la misma porque
nuestra masa es tan pequeña comparada
con la masa de la tierra que básicamente
no va a haber aceleración para la tierra
aún cuando las fuerzas en nosotros y en
la tierra sean iguales estas dos son la
pareja de fuerzas de la tercera ley de
newton y estas dos siempre van a estar
juntas tienen que ser iguales no importa
qué pase estas dos fuerzas siempre van a
ser iguales sin importar si esta caja es
muy delgadita o es muy chiquita se esté
acelerando o no se esté acelerando si
esté pegada en una pared o asentada en
una mesa o incluso calle no por el
espacio estas dos fuerzas deben siempre
ser opuestas e iguales esto es debido a
la tercera ley de newton y ahora qué
pasa con esta otra fuerza que estaba
ejerciendo la mesa sobre la caja
esta es la fuerza en la caja
ejercida por la mesa y ahora me es muy
fácil encontrar la fuerza acompañante de
esta que acabo de dibujar simplemente
voy a invertir las etiquetas aquí y en
lugar de ser una fuerza hacia arriba va
a ser una fuerza hacia abajo tiene la
dirección opuesta es una fuerza hacia
abajo que se ejerce en la mesa y es
ocasionada por la caja
así que aquí tengo mi otra fuerza que
está en la mesa y es ocasionada por a y
es igual y opuesta a la fuerza que la
mesa ejerce sobre la caja estas dos
fuerzas son la pareja de fuerzas de la
tercera ley de newton estas fuerzas van
a ser siempre iguales y opuestas sin
importar que pase la fuerza en ejercida
por la mesa y la fuerza en la mesa
ejercida por la caja siempre siempre van
a ser iguales y en dirección opuesta
pero la fuerza en a ejercida por la mesa
no tiene por qué ser igual a la fuerza
ejercida en la caja ocasionada por la
tierra resuelta coincide que sean
iguales y opuestas al menos en el caso
en el que no tenemos aceleración alguna
pero si pusiéramos todo esto dentro de
un elevador o dentro de algún cohete que
tenga una gran aceleración hacia arriba
aun cuando tengamos una aceleración
hacia arriba
la pareja de fuerza siempre va a ser
igual así que la fuerza en a por la mesa
va a ser igual a la fuerza en la mesa
por y siempre van a ser iguales y de la
misma manera la fuerza en la tierra pura
y la fuerza en a por la tierra también
siempre van a ser iguales pero ahora
estas dos fuerzas ya no van a ser
iguales pues porque no son pares de
fuerzas podrían ser iguales y opuestas
en ciertas circunstancias pero no
siempre tiene que ser así
generábamos esta caja hacia arriba esta
fuerza debido a la aceleración en la
caja va a tener que ser mayor que la
fuerza en la caja por la tierra y éstas
ya no serán iguales resumimos lo que
hablamos la tercera ley de newton es un
enunciado de fuerzas que se encuentran
en objetos diferentes y debido a que son
objetos diferentes estas fuerzas nunca
se pueden cancelar para encontrar la
fuerza acompañante de la tercera ley de
newton solamente intercambiamos las
etiquetas de los nombres de los objetos
después de haber identificado el par de
objetos que están interactuando la
pareja de fuerzas de la tercera ley de
newton tienen que tener la misma
magnitud y el sentido opuesto pero es la
misma magnitud sin importar que uno de
los objetos sea más masivo que el otro o
cualquier otra propiedad que nos haga
parecer que puede tener una mayor fuerza
en la tercera ley de newton si estos son
los objetos que están interactuando sus
fuerzas su pareja de fuerzas siempre
tendrá la misma magnitud
y dirección opuesta las fuerzas se
generan instantáneamente y hay que tener
cuidado porque algunas fuerzas dan la
impresión de ser pareja de fuerzas dan
la impresión de ser pares de fuerzas o
fuerzas compañeras que son iguales y
opuestas pero no necesariamente son
parejas de la tercera ley de newton
podrían ser iguales y opuestas por
alguna otra razón